بيان وكيليان مبابي يقلب حسابات باريس سان
جيرمان
اوكرانيا
وايطاليا تحتفل امام اسبانيا بقميص خاص
هذه الاخبار وغيرها نقدمها لكم من العربيه
رياضه اهلا بكم
في خطوه مفاجئه اصدر نجم باريس سان جيرمان
بيانا رسميا بخصوصي تمديد عقده مع الجيش
وابلغ امبابي الاداره برغبته في الرحيل
وعدم تمديد عقده الى ما بعد عام 2024 هذا
القرار سيجبر باريس لبيع النجم الاول
لديهم تفاديا لانتقاله مجانا خلال الصيف
المقبل كما يبدو ان رحيل بنزيما عن ريال
مدريد اغرم مبابي بالمغادره نحو العاصمه
الاسبانيه ليكون النجم الاول للفريق
نبقى مع اخبار سان جيرمان ومع بدء
الميركاتو الصيفي الساخن تلق نيمار عرضا
مغريان للانتقال من فريقه الى احد الفرق
في مدرسه برازيليه قادو منتخب السنبا تلقى
عرضا عبر رساله خاصه من احد متابعيه على
انستغرام حيث عرض عليه الانتقال مقابل
تقديمي وجبه الغداء له لمده عام كامل داخل
المدرسه وايضا تذكره لحضور نهائي بطوله
ولايه باهيا
لاول مره منذ بدء الاجتياح الروسي
لاوكرانيا زار نجم ارسنال الكسندر البلاد
رفقه اسطوره المنتخب الاوكراني اندري
اللاعبانزا رامي مدينه
الواقعه الشماليه البلاد ووقف على حجم
الدمار الذي اصابها وينظم
مباراه خيريه ستخصص عائداتها لاعاده بناء
احد المدارس المدمره في المدينه كما حظي
الثنائي باستقبال رسمي من طرف رئيس البلاد
احتفالا بمرور 125 عاما على تاسيس الاتحاد
الايطالي سيرتدي منتخب خاصا عندما يواجه
اسبانيا في نصف نهائي دوري الامم
الاوروبيه اللون الابيض سيكون طاغيا على
خطوط
ذهبيه كلاسيكيه من شركه اديداس التي
تعاقدت حديثا مع الاتحاد الايطالي ويعد
هذا الزي شبيها بذلك الذي لعبت به ايطاليا
اول مباراه لها في تاريخها وكانت امام
فرنسا عام 1910
[موسيقى]